So my gut says I should group by, by date
first? Because I'm, when I think about this, it's thinking like
how many tickets were sold this month and then within
that month, how would those tickets distribute? How many were each?
>> And you're right. You should be grouping
by date first because that's the overarching categorization.
>> Okay.
>> So. Grab the purchase date field and then drag it above.
>> Above.
>> Ticket type.
>> Oh, cool.
>> Yeah, but, the thing right now with purchase date is it's everyday.
>> Everyday.
>> And we don't want that.
>> We want to do it by month.
>> Right. So, if we, click that little arrow,
and then Group by Dates, or Group Dates By.
>> Yes, that's awesome.
>> Calendar month.
>> Alright, so October had 20. One which is VIP, that's awesome. Okay.
>> So again this is just a preview. So don't
freak out if it doesn't show all of the records.
because I know sometimes people do.
>> Okay, should I hit Save and then?
>> Yeah click Save always.
>> As.
>> Save As, yeah. That was close.
>> Okay,
>> Total revenue over time.
>> Yeah, I'll say by monthly.
>> Oh, by month. Yup.
>> Save and Run?
>> Save and Run.
>> Oh, that's so cool. So we've got May 2013,
we had 14 VIP tickets and 17 General Admission. June,
a lot of people bought tickets. All right, this is very cool. So
now I, I mean I want to make a chart. I'm going to fool around.